[Music]
well without question the most dominant
player in the history final exam is Fox
News at night
anchor shannon bream last fall she was
unleashed on our hapless Fox staff she
collected nine scalps in a row before
the rampage finally came to an end
thanks to Leland Vitter boy that was a
showdown here are some highlights Amazon
the company just announced an
interesting new service for a fee you
can have your delivery driver do what
with your Amazon packages
Shannon brain make them inside your
house don't believe that it's too weird
but we're gonna see if you're right on
our table tack tightening Amazon is
taking things a few steps farther
literally delivering those packages not
just your doorstep I mean I've been
watching news programming
would you let ever sign into your home
hacks hit the no on Sunday night a
former US president threw out the first
pitch the World Series game in Houston
Texas who wasn't shannon bream Bush 43
Bush 43 as distinct from 41 to the tape
we go 43 taking the field in Houston
where he's greeted by its father former
President George HW Bush who gave him
the ball such an amazing sight to
presidents on the same diamond and then
President Bush winding up and throwing a
strike of course have you tested these
lights President Trump was embroiled in
a controversy during his stop in Japan
this week some called it a fake
controversy he was blasted for dumping a
whole box of food into which kind of
animal enclosure shannon grill a koi
pond not a llama enclosure a koi pond to
the tape later mr. Trump feeding Asian
carp at a koi pond first tossing
spoonfuls of fish before empty in the
entire box that was the greatest video
forget it you're getting everything was
so good did you did you no answer but I
can't get our returning champion leaves
once again the champion no the score is
two to one shannon bream daddy henry and
shannon i want to congratulate you first
winner of the mouth-breathing mug it is
my honor presidency Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is under scrutiny over
Thanksgiving vacation she shared a
photograph on social media of a dish she
had made at home but at least one
reporter said it looked too good to be
real and accused her of faking that dish
what food did she make Shannon Bree
makan pie pecan pie also his pecan pie
to the tip we go White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders under
fire this weekend after she posted this
posted a picture of this pie
she said she baked it let me tell you
something she's been making this pie for
years years don't ever mess with a
southern woman and her homemade pies
shannon bream okay so watching the two
champions next to each other we start to
understand the key to this game your
lightning-fast cat-like reflexes yeah ex
49ers player Colin Kaepernick was just
presented with the coveted Muhammad Ali
legacy award during a Sports Illustrated
Sports Awards ceremony which famous
person a singer presented him with that
award saying quote Kaepernick has a
selfless heart Shannon bring Beyonce
Beyonce says shannon bream to the tape
we go ladies and gentlemen I'm so proud
and humbled to present the Muhammad Ali
legacy award to Colin Kaepernick I
accept this award
knowing that the legacy of Muhammad Ali
is that of a champion of the people
thank you both Shannon your rain remains
in place another better than any other
competitor correctly final question
Disney has unveiled its new robot
version of the President of the United
States Donald Trump it's in the Hall of
Presidents exhibit in the Magic Kingdom
there's a problem though many say the
robot looks nothing like the president
but like which actor instead shannon
bream Jon Voight
well that's a weird guess if you get
this right you win to the tape some on
the internet say it looks like a bloated
john-boy john-boy it's never gone and
brain ladies and gentlemen I can't
believe it okay so you win this week we
run our prizes so this week we have a
small bottle of non-alcoholic champagne
that we're going to give like it do I
get to like spray it it takes a lot like
bubbly water but it's it's delicious
which senator announced he is retiring
this year possibly paving the way for
Mitt Romney to run for his seat shannon
bream orrin hatch retiring
I think it's Chris Dodd ballistic
Grayson well the longest serving
Republican senator Orrin Hatch will not
seek re-election this year the 83 year
old lawmaker from Utah announcing his
retirement after serving since 1977
shannon bream don't feel bad it was in
the car don't you get our airplane size
champagne enjoy it it's delicious know
what I always do Chris Starr well you
really weren't worthy opponent last week
she completed a full Brady Bunch beating
Chris Starr wall to run her record to
nine and O tonight she goes for her
tenth straight win against America's
News headquarters host Leland Vitter a
man famous for his news acuity the
president just unveiled his latest
nickname this time for Senator Dianne
Feinstein of California
what was that nickname was it a sleepy
Diane
sneaky Diane C swampy Diane Weiland
vitter I'm going with sneaky sneaky
Diane not swampy sneaky not sleepy roll
tape
we do have this tweet last hour what was
it 20 minutes ago president the fact
that sneaky Diane Feinstein sneaky Diane
fine see here we go look at sloppy Steve
sneaky Diane Feinstein he's trying to
low me Wow this is without precedent can
I can it over yes you met you can hand
this is the coveted mouth breather Mike
I'm crouched do you mr. America well I
am gracious for for you and your
tomorrow the other Lee congratulations
to you Lila Nader shannon bream you've
been a fierce competitor terrifying
competitor looking forward to
graduations thank you nothing in this
life lasts forever even a streak like
that after nine wins shannon bream
passed the final exam crown to leland
Vitter whatever happened to him by the
way